Let's now think about the problem of
sorting n elements in a two-level
hierarchy.
Initially, let's assume
a processor is sequential.
Here's a natural scheme based
on the merge sort idea.
Start by logically dividing the input
into chunks of size proportional to, but
no greater than, z, so
that a single chunk fits in fast memory.
Next, read a chunk of the input
from slow memory into fast memory.
Then sort this chunk.
I'll refer to this sorted output sitting
in fast memory as a sorted run, or
just run for short.
As a mnemonic,
this left to right arrow is to remind
you that this chunk is sorted.
Since the run is now sorted,
write it back to slow memory.
You'll repeat this process
on each input chunk.
Assuming each of the input chunks was of
size F times Z, where F is some constant
less than one, then you'll end up with
about N/F times Z sorted runs in total.
I'll refer to everything we just
did as phase one of the procedure.
Again, that's partition the input
into approximately Z size chunks.
And then for each chunk, you read
a chunk, sort it and write it back.
Following the merge sort idea,
in phase two,
you want to merge all the sorted
runs into a single final sorted run.
Before discussing that, let's analyze
phase one the partition sorting step.